[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas de ces mini psy d'aujourd'hui en
france l'écho et les violences
n'existait avant leur confinement
et pendant ce compliment c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre les captures les
taux de féminicide a plus que je dis pas
doublé mais bien monté
forcément on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres officiels c'est très difficile
gros n'est jamais n'est jamais loin
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya un huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux repas à 3
[Musique]
en europe les pays les plus touchés par
le virus commence également à lever les
restrictions première bouffée d'air en
en espagne pour les enfants depuis six
semaines
seul pays au monde à leur avoir interdit
de sortir reprise des activités
industrielles 90 pour l'italie les
élèves italiens eux reprendront le
chemin de l'école qu'en septembre
l'épidémie a tué plus de deux cent mille
personnes dans le monde au moyen-orient
l'iran ne serait plus dans le rouge en
croire la déclaration du ministère de la
santé
la turquie elle libre du matériel
médical dans le monde mais pas toujours
dans le respect des normes
on va le voir
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche le premier
ministre français a encore quelques
heures pour consulter avant de présenter
sa copie mardi à l'assemblée nationale
les grands principes du déconfinement du
11 mai seront ensuite soumis à un vote
des députés
un plan qui comporte six thèmes dévoilée
par edouard philippe aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux la santé l'école le
travail les commerces et les transports
ainsi que les rassemblements un vote à
l'assemblée mardi qualifié d' imposture
par jean luc mélenchon comme l'est
républicain le leader de la france
insoumise réclame plus de temps pour
étudier les modalités de ce confinement
jean luc mélenchon a déjà prévenu que
son groupe votera contre le plan
présenté mardi par edouard philippe
regarder tracking et plans de
déconfinement déclarations et vote
bloqué dans la foulée un post sur ce
régime n'écoute personne et brutalisent
tout le monde
et voyez également la réaction de
nicolas dupont aignan il est président
de debout la france et député de la 8e
circonscription de l'essonne
comment veux tu es sur eux des traits
généraux et pas les détails
enfin j'ai pas compris d'ailleurs je
pensais que c'était une plaisanterie on
vote sur quelque chose de sérieux on est
des gens sérieux
on représente la nation donc moi
j'aimerais qu'ils appelant sérieux après
chacun se détermine moi j'attends de le
lire je bats l'inventer ce plan nous à
debout la france nous avons fait des
propositions nous sommes programmés
confinement il faut sortir du
confinement
d'ailleurs entre nous si on avait eu les
masses que les tests on aurait pu avoir
exactement le confinement à la demande
si je puis dire beaucoup plus
intelligent maintenant moi j'attends je
prends les choses telles qu'elles sont
j'attends de savoir combien masquer le
gouvernement a vraiment qu'ils arrêtent
d'une raconter des histoires combien de
tests pour en maîtriser et en fonction
de ces deux paramètres
j'ajouterai le contrôle des frontières
nationales j'ajouterai l'autorisation
prescrire le traitement à la chloroquine
et puis ensuite à déconfinement
progressif les commerces eux retourner
au travail en étant testé
puis à la sein du déconfinement la
possibilité pendant l'été d'avant des
centres de loisirs qui accueille les
enfants des écoles
en attendant une rentrée sérieuses sur
des bases solides au mois de septembre
enfin c'est du bon sens absolu que je
propose la cote de confiance de
l'exécutif en baisse à moins de 48
heures de la présentation de ce plan de
sortie selon un sondage ifop pour le jdd
vous le voyez seuls 39% des sondés
croient en la capacité de l'exécutif à
faire face efficacement à la crise
sanitaire c'est une baisse de 7 points
par rapport à la semaine dernière
le conseil scientifique régulièrement
consulté par l'exécutif dans ces crises
a publié de son côté une liste de
recommandations pour réussir le
déconfinement selon les experts par
exemple le port d'un masque dans les
lieux publics et pas seulement dans les
transports les lycées ou les collèges
doit être systématique
voyez les préconisations en images
[Musique]
et dans cette crise la situation des
personnes âgées en maison de retraite
est sans doute l'une des pires en france
elles sont confrontées au risque mortel
de l'épidémie mais aussi à la solitude à
la détresse psychologique et d'isolement
le bilan des morts dans ces
établissements s'élève à plus de 1800
8500 décès selon les chiffres officiels
et depuis quelques jours les mesures
d'isolement ont été assouplies par
l'exécutif ils peuvent recevoir la
visite de leurs proches mais sous
certaines conditions pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec anne sophie
pelletier député européenne la france un
saut misé anciennes aides
médico-psychologiques auteurs deux ehpad
une honte française
bonsoir anne sophie pelletier merci
d'être un drame
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt
france les ehpad est ce que ce sera elle
a honte de cette crise je prends les
termes de votre livre évidemment après
le drame de la canicule qui l'ont déjà
subi le coronavirus aussi ce sera
quelque chose d'extrêmement à dramatique
pour eux n'hésitent pas et est déjà une
ronde française avant cette épidémie est
avec cette épidémie on ne fait que
surligner ce que déjà les soignants
criquets c'est à dire le manque de
moyens cette épidémie aujourd'hui dans
les ehpad c'est un monstre qui rentre
dans des établissements pour personnes
âgées dépendantes et je crains que ce
soit pire que la canicule de 2003 et si
vous me permettez je ne voudrais pas
penser qu aux ehpad
mais je voudrais prendre à un prisme un
peu plus larges de la vieillesse parce
que la dépendance elle commence au
domicile et nous avons eu aujourd'hui à
nombre de décès à domicile qui est de
9000 personnes dont on ne parle pas dans
les chiffres et je voudrais penser aux
auxiliaires de vie à domicile je
voudrais penser aux aides à domicile qui
n'ont pas eu de protection pas de masque
pour aller s'occuper de leurs
bénéficiaires ça s'appelle comme ça j'ai
fait ce métier et qui aujourd'hui porte
la culpabilité à la fois de pouvoir être
vecteur d'un virus qui on le sait touche
particulièrement les personnes âgées est
à la fois et bien on leur a demandé de
prendre des risques dès finalement de
faire des choix un peu
cible autant pour les soignants tous les
personnels des ehpad est en fait tous
les personnels qui s'occupe des
personnes les plus fragiles vous parlez
d'un chiffre de 9000 personnes décédées
à domicile cela concerne les personnes
âgées où toutes les personnes qui sont
décédées à domicile nous n'avons pas
pour l'instant de catégorisation mais
par exemple dans mon département le jura
on est à + 26 % de morts à domicile
particulièrement sur les personnes âgées
dans le contexte on est à plus de 160 8
% de taux de mortalité on voit bien que
ce virus s'attaque évidemment aux plus
fragiles et je voudrais aussi il a passé
un message nous avons perdu un médecin
urgentiste à lons le saunier dans le
jura médecin urgentiste qui s'est battu
pour que la santé soit un bien commun et
qui est décédé ducobu 19 pensent qu'il
n'avait pas été assez protégé donc
malheureusement je pense que nous ne
pourrons faire les comptes
c'est terrible à dire mais que quand
cette pandémie sera terminée avec les
études démographiques par exemple là je
pense que la polémique n'est pas de mise
il faut surtout penser à sauver le plus
de monde possible dont les personnes
âgées
le fait d'avoir pu rouvrir les ehpad aux
proches pour autoriser les visites à ces
personnes c'est important c'était une
chose essentielle pour eux oui c'était
une chose essentielle parce que il y à
des personnes âgées qui ne décideront
pas du coup vite dans les ehpad et
heureusement mais on le voit ce
confinement est difficile surtout quand
vous avez des troubles cognitifs et nos
personnes âgées dans les ehpad et des
remontées que nous avons à et bien c'est
un isolement psychologique qui induit un
glissement finalement un glissement dans
la pathologie et un haut personnage et
un sourire d'un proche
c'est important et ça évitera en tout
cas c'est tout le monde est bien protégé
c'est tout le monde est bien protégé à
ce qu'il y ait ces glissements dans les
ehpad les aînés ce sont les grands
oubliés de cette crise selon vous
on l'a dit parfois là j'étais un critère
de sélection notamment dans les hôpitaux
oui mais les aînés ça fait pas depuis la
pandémie qu'on se rend compte que ce
sont les grands oubliés
vous avez certainement déjà passé des
reportages sur la catastrophe dans les
ehpad est le manque de moyens les aînés
ont toujours été les grands oubliés mais
pas que les aînés les personnes en
situation de handicap aussi donc encore
une fois on se rend compte parce que
nous avons fait un référé au niveau du
conseil d'état avec la cgt santé et fo
santé
nous avons fait un référé pour demander
des comptes au gouvernement
nous avons été déboutés de toutes nos
demandes c'est à dire les test
systématique et régulier ainsi que les
masques et les livraisons de masques
dans les ehpad toutes nos demandes ont
été rejetées
on voit bien encore que nos aînés ne
sont pas la priorité de nos gouvernants
et là c'est tout c'est toute une
génération qui est en train de partir
et peut-être sur n'aura le temps
auparavant si pour les familles parce
que je ne veux pas les oublier mais pour
les familles qui ne peuvent voir leurs
proches décédés parce qu'il y a les
rites funéraires qui sont complètement
arrêtée depuis cette pandémie
et bien moi je voudrais aussi penser aux
familles parce que je ne sais pas
comment ils vont faire leur deuil
comment ils vont réussir à faire leur
deuil la loi sur le grand âge est
essentiel plus que jamais dans ce
contexte il faudra tirer les leçons en
tout cas et revoir complètement à la
politique les concernant mais ça fait
des années que nous le dise on y lit un
très bon rapport circonstancié de ma
collègue caroline fiat qui déjà demandé
à ce que des ratios personnel résidents
soit augmentée nous avons vu des grandes
grèves en 2018 comme le 31 janvier et le
15 mars où les personnels soignants
demandait plus de moyens et puis vous
m'excuserez je vais être très radical
mais à un moment donné j'espère que nous
tirons des leçons de l'histoire est que
plus jamais il n'y aura des pâtes privé
à but lucratif et c'est la logique
allemand qui finalement marchandises la
vieillesse la logique devient la visite
est pas une marchandise
effectivement la logique de rentabilité
de certains
ces établissements on a fait des
reportages ici sur rt france sur cette
question
donc il va falloir revoir peut-être un
autre modèle pour la prise en charge de
ses aînés les réinsérer dans dans dans
toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles et quelles que
soient les âges peut-être la difficulté
c'est que quand les personnes âgées sont
en ehpad
ça veut dire qu'elles sont dépendantes
et qu'elles n'ont plus la possibilité de
racheter c'est de rester chez elle donc
ce n'est pas une raison pour leur
enlever leur citoyenneté parce que quand
une personne âgée par passent les portes
d'un ehpad l etat visibiliser les
soignants sont invisibilité le personnel
et invisibilité et revoir une politique
du grand âge sir de la solidarité
je pense que nous leur devons nous leur
devons parce que nous avons encore des
personnes âgées qui ont fait la guerre
qui ont qui se sont battus pour que nous
ayons des conflits sociaux que emmanuel
macron est en train de détruire petit à
petit mais cette solidarité nationale
elle est à mon sens juste du bon sens
parce que nous leur devons beaucoup
vous savez chez les personnes âgées
c'est un choix de métier le travailler
avec des personnes âgées et c'est un
choix de métier parce que jamais vous
n'apprendrez dans les livres d'histoire
ce que eux sont capables de vous
raconter jamais et nous leur devons
cette reconnaissance cette
reconnaissance d'avoir ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui donc la politique du grand
âge pour qu'elle soit plus juste et bien
c'est déjà de remettre la vieillesse
dans le giron du public plus des pas de
priver et c'est aussi plus non plus
parce qu'on parle de la survie de la fin
de vie pardon mais c'est aussi remettre
la mort dans le giron du public parce
qu'il est inconcevable que selon vos
moyens vous ayez les possibilités ou pas
dans ternes et d'enterrer pardon je suis
arrivé excusez moi j'ai la reprise mais
d'enterrer vos proches dignement ou pas
remettons tout s'est tu
tout ce pan de la société dans le giron
du public et soyons solidaires de nos
anciens de nos aînés de nos sages
qui nous apporte beaucoup qui nous
apprennent beaucoup et qui eux ont tiré
des lits sont des leçons de l'histoire
qui sont finalement le bon sens juste le
bon sens vous parliez de ces familles
qui ont perdu un proche dans cette crise
le fait de pouvoir faire son deuil
dignement n'est pas possible vu les
circonstances avec le déconfinement le
11 mai est ce que les choses pourraient
s'améliorer
je ne sais pas vous savez parce que les
le protocole funéraires sont très
particulier avec cette crise du que
vides les personnes âgées qui décède en
ehpad sont mises
excusez moi ça va être un peu dur mais
sont mis dans des housses mortuaires et
souvent les familles n'ont pas accès à
leurs proches ne passe pas les voir une
dernière fois
donc j'espère en tout cas que avec ces
nouvelles mesures qui sont prises et
bien les familles pourront commencer la
première étape de deuil mais c'est
tellement violent tellement violent pour
les familles parce que je veux le
rappeler les familles ne place pas leurs
personnages et dans les ehpad par
plaisir elles le font parce qu'elles
n'ont pas le choix elles n'ont pas le
choix et elle espère que leurs
personnages et leurs proches leurs
parents seront pris en soins dans toute
la dignité qui leur est dû et ce n'est
pas le cas ça fait des années que ce
n'est pas le cas donc avec ces nouvelles
mesures
peut-être probablement ça aidera les
familles mais en tout cas j'ai bien peur
qu après cette crise sanitaire cette
pandémie
ces chocs terribles eh bien on est des
familles qu'ils soient dans une
souffrance incommensurable et j'ai bien
peur que les soignants qui travaillent
en ehpad
et bien soit soir avec le regard d'une
personne âgée qui en train de décider
parce qu'on ne l'a pas pris à l'hôpital
et que cela augmente en tout cas les
risques psychosociaux de ces femmes et
ces hommes qui ont été envoyés en
première ligne sans protection et on en
parlera bien évidemment de ce suivi de
ces personnes évidemment qui ont été
face à des situations traumatisantes
merci beaucoup à anne sophie pelletier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france
et la question que tous les français se
posent auront ils accès à un masque le
11 mai prochain à en croire une note du
ministère de l'économie publié par le
jdd
la réponse est non puisque selon le
texte l'ensemble des besoins de
protection en tissu ne pourra être
couvert le 11 mai au démarrage le nombre
d'unités disponibles sera nettement
insuffisant pour donner plus d'un ou
deux masques à chaque personne voilà
pour cette note
il faudra attendre le 18 pour atteindre
les objectifs selon bercy
le prix d'un masque sera fixée à 5 euros
maximum d'unités
il sera disponible dans les bureaux de
tabac en pharmacie ou bien en grande
distribution pour ceux qui pourront se
l'offrir
voyez ce que 10 de ce déconfinement le
11 mai jean françois corty
il est médecin et ancien directeur des
opérations internationales de médecins
du monde
ce qui est exact ce qui est sûr c'est
que c'est un pari d'avoir décidé que le
11 mai puisse être une date pour le
déconfinement parce qu'on le sait et le
on est toujours dans une logique
médecine de catastrophe il ya toujours
un nombre conséquent de personnes qu'il
faut soigner en réanimation mais aussi
en médecine de ville avec un système de
santé qui est sous tension et puis une
immunité dite collective qui à -10% ça
veut dire qu'il reste beaucoup de gens
qui potentiellement pourront être
affectés avec des formes graves de la
maladie donc il va falloir un nombre de
masques conséquent énorme parce
qu'évidemment il ya une tension forte
entre la santé publique libertés
individuelles et gratifié comique va
falloir retourner travailler mais il ne
faudra pas sacrifier les personnes qui
vont être sur le terrain donc une
tension très forte et en fait ce qui est
important c'est que cette épidémie elle
va se combattre sur le terrain ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'il va falloir à les
dépister isoler les personnes qui seront
on suspecte et puis surtout conserver
les mesures barrières avoir des masques
pour se protéger il va en falloir
beaucoup et c'est un fondamental pour
réussir sur les confinements et ne pas
sacrifier un pan de la population
le ministre de l'agriculture a appelé
début avril les français à continuer à
manger du poisson pour soutenir la
filière
sauf que le secteur de la pêche est
quasiment à l'arrêt depuis le début du
confinement la situation est très
compliquée économiquement pour certains
pêcheurs
même si des aides européennes sont
envisagées voyez ce reportage à
cherbourg et les signes et solène gaudin
cynthia lauvergeon et morgane france ont
quatre chalutiers à quai depuis bientôt
six semaines
du jamais vu pour david leroy marin
pêcheur depuis 30 ans et plus gros
armateur du coton temps les rentrées de
17 ans président a dit qu'il fallait
confiné on a fait rentrer nos quatre
bateaux plus d'un mois comme ça c'est
une première
nous ce qu'on veut c'est de retourner
l'année alpiq voilà que comme base que
bâton travail qui allie rentrées
d'argent que les grands un salaire comme
on était avant reprendre la mer
impensable tant que les gestes barrières
sont de rigueur à bord d'un bateau de
pêche la proximité entre les marins est
inévitable ils sont un cadre dans un
mètre carré grosso modo la manutention
les cov ça se fait toujours à deux dans
la cale c'est pareil ils sont à deux qui
sont toujours côte des uns des autres
voiliers le l'interphone seul de l'école
des pêches pour remonter veut remettre
leur gréement
alors on va pas dire à 20 ans je me bats
si magique parce qu'on n'est pas à
mettre la vase y passer jeu passera
après c'est sympa c'est pas possible
autre impact de l'épidémie des revenus
qui plonge depuis le début du
confinement cet armateur perd cinq cent
mille euros de chiffre d'affaires par
mois pour sortir la tête de l'eau
l'union européenne a accordé aux
professionnels du secteur une aide
financière mais cette indemnité sera
versée seulement à l'horizon 2021
en attendant seul moyen de ne pas couler
redémarrer avec en ligne de mire le 11
mai une reprise néanmoins conditionnée
par l'activité de ses clients
voilà toute façon pas clairement que les
restaurants sont fermés les cantines les
collectivités tout ça que tout est fermé
pour nous
on va prendre notre poisson c'est sur un
certain non si c'est pour la la mer et
puis dire en fin de compte bacon route
et il n'y en a que c'est une mauvaise
vente
les gosses j'en appelle à vous donner
comme nous on est payé à la peur on aime
on n'a pas de fixe dgo ils vont faire un
enfin la tête en france 16 mille
pêcheurs professionnels sont concernés
tous navigue à vue en attendant une
reprise générale en europe les pays les
plus touchés par le virus commence
également à lever les restrictions
première bouffée d'air en espagne pour
les enfants depuis six semaines ils sont
enfermés depuis six semaines
l'espagne est le seul pays au monde à
leur avoir interdit de sortir
reprise des activités industrielles 80
pour l'italie les élèves italiens eux ne
reprendront le chemin de l'école qu'en
septembre comment l'europe est elle en
train de ressortir progressivement de
plusieurs semaines de confinement total
ou partiel à chaque pays sa solution
regardez clément hospital ses rues vidée
de ses habitants ces populations
retranchés chez elle voilà maintenant
six semaines que l'europe vit au ralenti
le vieux continent s'apprête à amorcer
son déconfinement amputé de plus de 120
milles de ses citoyens au royaume uni
boris johnson prépare son grand retour
après son infection kovy 19 début avril
le pays vient de dépasser le seuil des
20 mille décès dans ces hôpitaux
le fait de passer la barre des 20000
décès nous rappelle à tous comme je les
dis en commençant cette présentation
qu'il est absolument essentiel
absolument essentiel que nous continuons
à suivre les directives de distanciation
sociale parce que nous voyons les
bénéfices que nous en retirons et nous
continuerons à constater ses bénéfices
mme nous ne continuerons a constaté la
réduction des décès que si nous
continuons tous allaient suivre
plus au sud en europe l'espagne autorise
des exercices physiques et les
promenades à partir de ce week end
jusqu'à leur soumis un confinement total
les mineurs de moins de 14 ans pourront
sortir une heure par jour des nouvelles
mesures de déconfinement s'appliqueront
à partir du 2 mai si l'épidémie de
coronavirus continue à reculer
c'est désescalade sera progressive
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
cela ne signifie pas que nous allons
retrouver soudainement toutes nos
activités
autre mobilité sociale mais que cela se
fera par étapes pour chaque domaine
d'activité des étapes successives seront
fixés un lent retour à la vie d'avant
qui n'est pas au goût de tout le monde à
berlin la police anti-émeute allemande a
arrêté une dizaine de manifestants
mobilisés contre les mesures de
confinement
la baisse du nombre de contaminations a
permis la réouverture de petits
commerces
mais les règles de distanciation sont
maintenus jusqu'au 3 mai outre-rhin en
italie les écoles rouvriront seulement
en septembre pour ne pas mettre en jeu
la santé des enfants selon giuseppe
compter une campagne nationale de tests
sérologiques commencera également début
mai sur cent cinquante mille personnes
pour vérifier la présence d'anticorps
chez la population de la plus meurtrie
d'europe
ailleurs dans le monde où l'épidémie a
tué près de plus de 200 mille personnes
à ce jour la cure qui enregistre plus de
2400 décès officiellement le pays qui
depuis la crise livres du matériel
médical des masques notamment à des
dizaines de pays mais pas toujours dans
le respect des normes clément hospital
dans les rues d'istanbul vendeurs à la
sauvette ou simples passants se
vêtissent de ces masques noirs appelé
nano masque
ils sont accessibles partout dans le
pays ils sont pourtant non conformes car
il ne protège pas contre le virus
je pensais être en sécurité les gens
autour de moi pensaient la même chose
rapidement on a appris que ces masques
de protéger même pas contre 1% du virus
ça m'a fait bizarre car les gens qui
travaillent dans les rues utilisent
majoritairement se masquer ces personnes
les ont achetés car il était accessible
les gens se sont rendu compte que les
masques servait à rien
tout le processus autour des masques
n'est pas clair d'abord ils nous ont dit
que ce n'était pas nécessaire d'en
porter et maintenant on est obligé de le
faire mais nous ne savons pas quels sont
les bons masque par exemple je porte ce
masque car il me semble répondent aux
normes sanitaires
mais je n'en suis pas certaine combien
de temps je dois le porter ou comment je
dois nettoyer la turquie est l'un des
plus importants producteurs de masques
sur le marché mondial entre 150 et 200
millions d'unités sont fabriqués chaque
année dans le pays
le boom de la demande créée par la
pandémie inspiré certains fabricants de
textile turque
les usines de confection ainsi mobilisé
leurs machines à coudre pour fabriquer à
leur tour des masques sans se soucier
davantage des normes internationales je
voudrais tout d'abord faire remarquer
que ce masque n'est pas un produit
médical bien qu'il ait appelé
nanotechnologique ils n'ont fait l'objet
d'aucun d'enregistrement ou
d'approbation les raisons pour
lesquelles nous ne devrions pas porter
ces masques sont qu'il ne filtre pas
suffisamment l'air ils ne peuvent donc
pas nous protéger contre la
contamination par micro gouttelettes
nous constatons également que la plupart
de ces masques noirs ne s'adaptent pas
bien au niveau du nez il ne lisait pas
suffisamment il n'est donc pas approprié
de les utiliser dans cette situation ces
masques vendu comme réutilisables sont
pourtant à usage unique comme
l'affirment le médecin s'il est utilisé
plus d'une fois
ce matériel de protection peut créer un
environnement propice à la croissance
des bactéries et des virus
ce business illégal a alerté interpol
qui affirme avoir saisi début mars 14
millions de dollars de produits
sanitaires potentiellement dangereux à
travers 90 pays
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes à rester
avec nous
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]